okay so this 63 year old woman was just
are you okay
chin do me a favor before she giving us
bring up the female gremlin from gremlin
to fry man hold on I'm talking spot on
female grim there's hit it tell me that
doesn't look what's up bro okay yes so
much okay so there's a lipstick issues
but other than that comparison but in
that weird and the nose - it's
impressive but you're so mean their
identity I was pretty good I done with
that casually I'm like in Providence
that's impressive okay so this 63 year
old high school teacher was recently
arrested for having sex with a 17 year
old student jump ride bud they don't
talk about whether it's a girl or a guy
they don't name the child or anything
but she is the newest sex scandal well
you just can't be here after dark
right yeah you can't feed after car
definitely can't get water on her when
you're 70 and your history teachers give
me some business I fell you need an A I
felt bad for do you do you don't feel
bad for the kid the 17 year old no
really 17 he's a he's a 17 year old boy
yeah that's the first you know yeah
that's I think that's legal in Vegas
that's legal that's legal in most
countries yeah yeah feel bad for her
Sweden's 15 she's a long an old lady and
then she's not married this young man
she provides mental if-- I feel bad I do
I do
well I understand that don't stand it if
it's a dude I got a problem I'm like I
wouldn't be a good judge I'd be like
well poor thing a little more info but
she looks identical to that gremlin
let's do also the 17 year old boy wasn't
that Keanu Reeves the problem any time
is when someone manipulates someone to
do something they don't want to do Yeah
right but we're creating these rules
about like when that is
when that happens when that happens when
someone has the intellect and the agency
to make a correct choice or when they're
being manipulated by promise she has an
hour of him right that is why if you
don't some give you that sort of I
telling about having a dick and putting
it in somebody that's different and
being strong and I'm an old lady a 63
year old lady isn't that much of a
threat is it she is that the wisdom know
she can talk me into it okay if you want
this in class he can't stand up she's
probably I don't think he does
when I was 17 I was all about you try to
bang you teach it off yeah well yeah I
mean yeah looks like it carried it right
I'm just saying but I think the reason
why why she got arrested right in a
position of power you are a teacher not
haven't dude when I was 17 and a teacher
hit on memory yeah I guess I have to
come after school and [ __ ] around with
her well you do have to arrest her
I'm not taking on a restaurant the
situation I guess and a lot of times I
don't but with that I just I like you
waste my sense a double staring it's a
hot teacher I know I know
fantastic but you softer it's still not
a la hey if you're a teacher you can't
you can't write know unless you're what
if you yeah if you're if you're a
teacher of anything you gotta like go
lay off you gotta laugh the kid like but
what about college professors were the
kids like 24 25 that's not illegal
that's a teacher get fired it might just
policy times but but that happens all
the homeboy from McDonald's gap he's
[ __ ] 50 [ __ ] 27 you're right and he
got fired because she was a cashier at
McDonough
but yes 70 mill he did well you got pay
up you got pay the man did you get let
him go CEO of McDonalds cereza Magritte
sometimes um sometimes all that stuff is
like that's not illegal that's against
policy she lose your job yeah this is
you this is like the players can't sleep
with the cheerleaders yeah the cops are
not gonna arrest you you can use later
can't sleep with the cheerleaders
absolutely not why I'm found upon its
frowned put it's frowned upon
yes we element
yeah that's weird what happens I was
after the cash here
what then a McDonald's employee and he's
a CEO it's essential relationship why is
that bad why would you care yeah why is
that I guess it cuz you could give her
because he's the Big Dawg
it's a while son she's getting promoted
okay it's a liability I guess it's a
very interesting thing because every
situation we make laws that are black
and white and we make rules and policies
that are black and white but really
every situation is unique is it was this
was this bad was this abusive or was it
not was even Z's you can be in a whole
other situation and just be a [ __ ]
Mentalist like David Blaine somebody and
completely trick some girl into having
sex with you but you don't have any
other relation it's like oh I'm just
being a pickup artist yeah we're using
like heavy psychological influence
technique well Harvey Weinstein right
that's our that's different but not all
in some case he's a racist no well no in
some case in the other case like if you
want being pretty woman to you're gonna
suck this dick and there are a lot of
girl to it alright that sounds good to
me like that that's where so that's
using leverage nitrogen power the other
one is just using is using like
influence and this kind of like but let
me ask you this black man sometimes guys
are attractive to women right and part
of what makes them attractive is the
fact that they are that they have a bad
there their seductive their intelligent
and there are a lot of young women that
are into that no doubt until the so is
power and power is attractive to so like
all the my thing is socially somebody if
you work with somebody you know if you
have a workplace because of all of this
stuff it would be it would be always
better to err on the side of caution
here's the thing most relationships
start that's right environment that's
right I don't think it's gonna make
people happier where you gonna meet
people I don't know people you in the
same key makes people hey Mary how's it
going you see everyday position you know
I'm saying it's a guy and you are gonna
get surprised it's the problem with law
because really we should be judging
intention rather than actual like
because thanks to people that use what
regular doing I actually was I actually
spent time with like a super pastor this
past weekend and someone asked him about
about
cuss words like saying [ __ ] or something
like that and he's a cool guy and he was
like he's like you know what it the word
stone the words don't matter it matters
what the intent was if like they were
intending even if you say like goddamn
it he's like they were talking about
saying that he's a pastor right he's
like that doesn't mean anything if you
didn't mean god damn it like you weren't
actually like damming this or like
actually like intending to say something
derogatory about the divinity in general
like you're just saying a phrase it
doesn't [ __ ] mean anything you know
what I mean so like but people but
religion has these doctrines that say
like don't say these blasphemous words
schools have these things don't say
these bad words she was cool with it
though yeah it was cool with it cuz I
was like well I was like that's awesome
I'd say [ __ ] yeah that's off exactly
[ __ ] yeah like that's the truth we see a
younger guy yeah for sure and dress
pretty cool yep yep yep yeah and he was
dope and it was like it was like all
right you get it it's not about it's not
about what you say it's about what this
is where they say McDonald's CEO could
fire for consensual and they put that in
quotes relationship with well you know
if it was a relationship did a lot of
these relationships are consensual it's
just against their policy though that's
just why the rules yeah McDonald's has
that policy that makes sense and I
understand it I understand a community
side or they don't want to deal with
libel you know you sign up for love
that's true
hey hey people get lonely I don't give a
[ __ ] how rich you are what kind of CEO
you're an older guy you're a CEO you
meet a girl you connect there's
something about her you guys fall in
love it just happens
[ __ ] maybe [ __ ] your job I don't know
maybe worth it
we want that prick snitched on them
Gaucho in the [ __ ] it was like a lot of
people oh my god Janine is dating Gary I
gotta fire this I think about that it's
just we all love to watch somebody die
we love failure it makes people feel
they just love it makes us feel bad
yourself
[ __ ] right you keep on keepin on mr.
chief officer i Ken McDonald country and
no heart anymore
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]